I was just backstage with Jack Nicholson
and Vice President Gore drinking I I
don't think he's running for president
my apologies uh well let's get right to
it
here are the exceptionally gifted
nominees for Best Supporting Actress
Adriana Barraza in Babel Cate Blanchet
notes on the scandal Abigail Breslin
Little Miss Sunshine Jennifer Hudson in
dreamville Rinko Kikuchi in babble
and the Oscar goes to Jennifer Hudson
Jennifer Hudson's road to the Oscar
began at a small church in Chicago where
she sang soul-stirring solos in the
Gospel Choir
oh my god I have to just take this
moment in cannot believe this look what
God can do
it's my grandmother how do you think I
was gonna win but why my grandmother was
here to see me now she was my biggest
inspiration for everything because she
was a singer and she had the passion for
it but she never had the chance and that
was the thing that pushed me forward to
continue but I'm so grateful to have my
mother here celebrating with me my
boyfriend my sisters and my brothers
back home and then I got two of them
here thank you all for being here and
supporting me I also like to thank Bill
Condon our director who's a genius oh my
god I unbelievable cast um I like to
thank the Academy definitely have to
thank God guess again uh he believed wow
I don't know what to say but I thank you
all for helping me keep the faith even
when I didn't believe thank you and God
bless
coming up Jerry Seinfeld and honorary
Oscar and a world premiere performance
by Celine Dion